mein name ist klar es genau wenn ich
wurde seit 1960 in dieser wohnung und
muss jetzt leider verlassen weil die
häuserzeile abgewiesen wird
ein umzug mit 86 jahren
weil das haus bald nicht mehr steht die
neustadt von johanngeorgenstadt wird es
bald nicht mehr geben
im grunde genommen habe ich in dieser
wohnung vieles schönes erlebt nach
trauriges aber das schöne überwiegt ist
derzeit ist traurig dass eben vor vier
jahren meine gemahlin verstorben ist
dass ich seitdem allein erleben eine
stadt deren arbeitslosen das ist
johanngeorgenstadt heute gerade noch
4500 menschen leben hier zu blütezeiten
waren es bis zu 40.000
jahrhunderte lang lebte die kleine stadt
im erzgebirge vom bergbau
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg wurde uran
für die sowjetische waffenproduktion
abgebaut arbeitskräfte kamen von überall
her
für sie wurde in den 1950 er jahren die
neustadt gebaut
doch dann brach der bergbau zusammen mit
der wende 1989 begann die neustadt zu
verweisen
die menschen zogen der arbeit hinterher
inzwischen gehören die gebäude der
wohnbau ag für geschäftsführer reiner
schneidenbach sind die brachliegenden
häuser vor allem eines teuer
hätten wir seit der wende nicht
abgerissen hätten wir heute in unseren
objekten 75 jahre stand schaut euch das
war abgerissen haben bereits seit 1994
sind es in anführungszeichen nur 30
prozent
1200 wohnungen sind schon weg mehr als
die hälfte im frühjahr 2013 sollen
wieder die abrissbagger durch die
neustadt rollen
der altersdurchschnitt der menschen
liegt hier bei 57 jahren
der bundesdurchschnitt beträgt nur 45
jahren der bevölkerung schon seiner
stadt stellt auch bürgermeister holger
schick vor immer neue schwierigkeiten
jetzt konkret ist es so dass wir also
nicht mehr das problem der abwanderung
haben was anfangen und enden und 19 wir
ja auch ein ganz wichtiger negative
rolle gespielt hat dass wir viele
menschen verloren haben
die neuen grossstadt keine arbeit mehr
hatten jetzt ist es mehr das problem
entstanden aus dieser zeit dass zu
wenige kinder geboren werden aber dafür
natürlich eine sehr hohe anteil älterer
bevölkerung da ist
die neue wohnung von klaus knauer liegt
in einem seniorenheim
sein sohn thilo hilft beim umzug er ist
einer der wenigen die in
johanngeorgenstadt geblieben sind
randstad ist für mich wirklich kindheit
aufgewachsen nicht so schnell gegangen
hier habe ich gefunden hatte ich dann
eine ganz kleine alte wohnung
es gab auch keine größeren von miranda
ein kind einmal durch ganz glücklich und
stände in baugrundstücke bekommen und
haben hier ein eigenheim gebaut und sind
dadurch immer noch mit dieser stadt ganz
dicke verbünden
auch für den vater ist und bleibt
johanngeorgenstadt heimat ein großen
vorteil hat diese wohnung auch mal hat
eine hervorragende sicht läuft teile von
johann statt
wenn ich mich herr lanz leben das sehe
ich sogar den ausgleich